[inaudible]
the Joe Rogan experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
Boom.
We are live in a hotel room in the middle of Melbourne,
Australia and next door to us is some sort of a religious institution,
Cathedral type scenario,
some fucking bunk ass bullshit.
Old World Voodoo House that's got their fucking bells ringing constantly.
They get to do that.
Imagine if you live next door to those assholes and it's like they decided today
cause a special time to bring the Gong so we don't know what's going on.
We thought it was like baby for,
for Paris because as we're doing this,
uh,
Tony and I just found out maybe an hour or so ago,
um,
that uh,
the,
uh,
the Paris attacks had gone on more than a hundred people are dead.
It was inside some,
some rock and roll
show,
some death metal death metal show.
One more reason it never go see a death metal concert hall ready.
That's an interesting place to attack.
Yeah,
it's pretty fucked up.
The whole thing is pretty fucked up.
I didn't know they had death metal than Paris.
It seems like it just wouldn't even exist.
They're like,
there'd be no base for that.
It turns out there was hundreds of people there.
I think more than that,
I think there's thousands.
I think it's a big,
I don't know.
Why would you think that death metal wouldn't be popular in parents?
Paris just seems like they're a little bit too like Prim and proper for a,
yeah.
No,
that's metal.
I think on paper they do like if we look at it from the past.
Yeah.
I don't think they're that Prim and proper.
I think Paris has a lot of like drinking and fucking and Gerard de Pardot like
almost almost thought it stopped.
It did stop.
Now they're just slowly gonging one,
two,
three.
How long have you been to do that?
I don't know.
This is like the biggest cathedral I've ever seen.
That right.
Things huge over.
It ended.
Yeah.
It's pretty big but something,
but they're the ones in New York City,
I think you're probably bigger.
They're really old.
Them.
Those old were saying before the started that those old religious houses,
those old buildings,
so like they don't make them like that anymore.
I wish they did.
That stuff's so cool with game of Thrones getting more popular,
you would think like there'd be more of that type of architecture happening.
Keep people wanting to create their own kingdoms and stuff.
I bet we do see more of it.
It's hard to create a kingdom today.
People are too hip.
Yeah,
they're aware.
We try and do.
Yeah.
Have you tried to make a religion today?
We're all your leaders
sex like,
like the Catholics have,
they'd be like,
wait,
what the Fuck Outta here?
Nobody would want to be the leader of that.
They're like,
I'll follow,
but I'm not going to lead.
Like,
what are the laws?
Like Scientology
is like the most recent of all the religions.
Right?
Cause that was started in the fifties or sixties.
Like whenever I forget,
I'm reading the middle of this book.
I can't even,
I can't finish it.
I agreed it and then I put it down.
So Lawrence Wright book going clear that a,
they started that.
Um,
it was the beginning of that,
uh,
Hbo Documentary.
That's how it started.
And,
uh,
I've,
I've watched the documentary and I keep getting into this book,
but it's so crazy that guy over on Harvard was sell fucking crazy.
That the idea that this guy could start this global movement that has,
who knows how many fucking thousands of people in it and then how many fucking
millions if not billions of dollars they've earned in real estate and how much
they pilfered from all these people that are inside of it.
It's,
it's crazy.
It
really is.
I think it really preys upon the people that like are the weakest,
I mean,
how do you believe that guy was a science fiction author?
Yeah,
that should be enough right there.
First thing at the top of this guy's resume is that he was a big science fiction
author.
I mean,
if George Lucas started a religion,
I guess maybe I'd probably be pretty correlated and join so many doors and be
like,
oh man,
fuck it.
I'm in.
And that's really the crazy part is I don't know.
Like,
I don't,
I mean,
I don't think I'll,
Ron Hubbard really got that famous off of like his science fiction.
Maybe.
Maybe I'm wrong.
Like I don't know.
But he was definitely no star wars.
Like you would think that,
and maybe that's why he did this.
Like he's like,
I haven't come up with a hit.
Maybe I'll just start a relationship.
No.
Well he is the most prolific author ever.
He wrote more books than anybody that's ever lived.
Yeah.
Which is another thing.
And that would be at the top of his resume that proves that he's full of
bullshit.
Just so much stuff.
He just kept writing.
Yeah.
Well he's the most prolific bullshit artist ever.
And the,
the,
the other thing you said,
his work was like all first drafts.
It seems like he never did a second draft ever.
He just,
whatever he thought he wrote down and just slobbered through the whole thing.
It's all like terrible,
terrible,
terrible writing.
It's all like,
and then the fetus is dropped,
the frozen volcano,
the people in the volcano.
And that's where your anxiety comes from.
The going clear is about releasing all of it.
Like all of his ideas and principles of the idea,
like the ideals of Scientology.
He outlined in the science fiction stories before he ever put him down as like
the actual reality of Scientology here.
Like you could see like if you go back over his older stuff,
you see him making this stuff up
[inaudible] and you know,
it's like on top of all that,
on top of it being wild,
they take so much money from these people.
10% right.
Is it a 10% thing?
And then it like if you do anything bad they like punish you and make you give
them money and stuff.
No,
it's true.
Like I was reading this article about that actress.
Uh,
she wasn't like Mike,
not Mike and Caroline Ray,
I think her name is.
She was in like some show with like Mike or Molly,
one of those
you talking about Leah Remini.
Yeah,
that's what I'm shooting the king and Queens.
she's in with Kevin Jane's show.
Kevin James.
That's what I always get.
Kevin,
James and Mike from Mike and Molly
big thick.
On.
Um,
but I guess like,
I guess she went to Tom and Tom Cruise and Katie Holmes wedding and like said
some stuff and everybody got mad at her and they charged her like a hundred
thousand bucks for it.
Like something crazy like that.
Well,
they didn't just charge her,
they made her go through hours and hours of retraining and auditing.
You know,
they go,
you go through this auditing thing where you have to sit down,
you go through every single last detail of everything you said and what you did
during the wedding.
And she had to apologize to Katie Holmes for ruining her special day.
And Oh,
I can see Lee Romney fucking it up though.
She's,
you know,
she's a bold woman.
Yeah.
She seems like a little party machine.
She gets a few champagnes center.
Sounds like she seems like she drinks and just starts auditing out loud,
you know.
Do you think this podcast is going to get fucked up by those gongs in the
background?
I think maybe it sort of gives it like a vibe,
like sort of a town knowing though like if you're listening to this right now
you'd be like,
are they fucking really good?
I like to do this with the gongs and their background.
There's a way in this room we could get away from it.
I think that's like the reality of where we are.
Yeah,
you're on the is unbelievably annoying that if I lived here I'd be so pissed if
I was trying to take my afternoon nap and this shit is going off.
Gung Gung,
Gung,
Gung Gung Jesus Christ.
Once upon a time walked upon the water,
gone,
gone.
I think it's because of the France thing,
but this people going in there,
it looks like a wedding.
You know what I was just thinking about,
cause I was reading all these tweets on Twitter about the Paris France thing,
like as it's happening and so many people are tweeting the same thing and
they're all going like,
you know,
pray for France,
pray for France.
And I'm just thinking of myself,
like I started thinking about prayer and what it is and it's,
and it's,
it just seems like it's something that people do to make themselves feel better.
Well,
it's definitely something people do to make themselves feel better,
but the ideas of positive thinking can correct things.
Yeah.
Can you imagine if there was like a,
can you imagine if there was studies that showed that praying did something,
what would happen?
Well,
what is the placebo effect?
Right?
The placebo effect is you believing that something is happening even though
there's no real chemical that you're like you're taking a sugar pill and just
believing that that sugar pill,
some Miracle Pill,
you can somehow or another enact a physical effect on your body.
I like the power of the mind.
Yeah.
It's,
it's real.
Like there is this real healing powers of the mind and if you apply that to
prayer,
like if you think that prayer really does help,
if you actually believe it,
it probably would have a similar effect,
at least physically to placebo effect on the person praying on the person who
believes.
Like,
if somebody prayed for you,
if you had something wrong with you on some unplayed prayed for you,
you might,
it might have a physical effect on you if you actually believe that they could
do it.
Like if you were,
if you had some Gandalf motherfucker hang around with you.
I see.
So if you believe that prayers work and somebody prays for you and you're like,
Oh man,
these people are praying for me.
Yeah.
Okay.
It could,
it could have an effect.
Yeah.
I think that there's probably all these untapped ways that we can help our body,
that we can like power up our immune system or overcome like certain,
certain things that are happening to our physical body just because our mind
believes it.
You know,
this is,
they've shown it with the placebo effect that it's a real effect that there is
really something going on,
but we don't know how to like voluntarily use that without tricking ourselves
for the most part.
Yeah.
You know how this guy,
Wim Hoff on my podcast,
fascinating fucking dude and he's,
um,
he holds like 26 world records.
He um,
summited Everest in his shorts with a like sandals on the fucking,
the ice ice cleats under the sandals and a,
he ran a half marathon in minus 40 degree weather with shorts on and no shirt
barefoot.
He's,
yeah,
he swam a hundred yards.
It was supposed to be 50,
but he couldn't figure out how to go under the ice.
Uh,
he swam under the ice and was supposed to be 50 yards,
but his retinas froze because the water was so fucking cold,
so he couldn't see where he was going.
So we wound up going twice as far with one breath.
He wound up swimming a hundred yards under the ice for the pull them out.
I couldn't find the hole in the ice.
He's,
he's,
he got 26 world records and a big part of his,
like his methodologies about breathing and about,
uh,
over oxygenating like,
like oxygen loading on your lungs,
but he's able to achieve these crazy states like that.
He uh,
had a,
a Dutch university or a hospital or university hospital inject him with a
Mycotoxin,
mycotoxin,
a biotoxin,
and in this a biotoxin that he like,
he showed that he can activate his immune system with his own mind.
Things that we thought were only autonomous sort of a
systems like your immune system.
Like he's able to actually physically activate it with his own mind.
So I think there's all sorts of different areas of the,
the human body that are,
we haven't really tapped into the full potential of,
that's probably what the,
the,
that's probably what the placebo effect shows.
It shows that we just don't know how to stimulate.
Like the average person doesn't know how to stimulate those,
those systems,
but it is possible.
We just don't know how to do it.
Yeah.
You know?
Hmm.
That's an interesting stuff.
Well,
it's interesting because we know that certain states are bad for your immune
system,
like being depressed and being stressed out or being fucked up or you can get
sick.
Like people get sick,
they get stressed,
they get worn out.
Like in that if you're calm and relaxed,
you can handle things better.
So we know that there's certain states of mind that are more beneficial for your
body.
Yeah.
We just don't know how like most people don't know how to achieve those certain
states.
A water over here,
it's interesting but
we also know like exercise,
like if you exercise that's pretty profound effect on your body.
Exercise a profound effect on your stress levels and that that effect in your
stress levels can change your health.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
Like I,
my whole clock and everything was all messed up yesterday cause we just flew to
Australia and I was waking up from a nap so I'm normally messed up after a nap
anyway.
But I was double messed up [inaudible] and I went down to the gym,
hit the steam room and it was unbelievable how I went from like 24% to 100%
yeah.
In an hour.
Yeah.
Just from sweating and sweating and sweating and like just getting some of the
blood flowing.
Yeah.
Get the blood flowing,
fire up the machine,
get all the systems working.
Yeah.
Well,
that's why I have always have a hard time trusting people that don't exercise.
Yeah,
try it.
Especially people that are like really emotional or overreact and they don't
exercise.
I'm like,
God damn it.
You don't have like a a mitigation process like it give you,
if you do,
it doesn't evolve,
you know,
like it has to be all mental.
It they don't have anything like physical.
When I was growing stress relief,
and I think it's like a Midwest thing,
I feel like it's,
maybe it's an east coast thing,
but I feel like I feel like maybe they have more,
maybe they're better at this now,
but I feel like they were,
they would just make it look like exercising.
They would tell you to exercise to lose weight.
There was never really,
I feel like nobody was really outgoing.
Lee saying that workout to make your mind stronger,
you know?
And I feel like maybe it's just California or maybe I just hang out with smarter
people now.
Maybe it's all of that.
But like now it's very clear to me why working out is important and it doesn't
matter how much you weigh,
but in a,
in Ohio I felt like that was that like you would never see someone with my build
running.
I feel like where I'm from really?
Yeah.
Skinny people don't run.
It nobody exercises there.
It's very bizarre.
People don't exercise in the middle of the country,
man.
It's creepy.
Are you sure it's creepy?
I mean,
and you survey not,
I mean I'm saying not everybody does an exercise,
but they definitely don't exercise like successful people exercise like
Californians exercise.
I mean there's obviously not everybody in California exercises,
but I don't know.
I just feel like,
I feel like big food companies and soda pop companies also don't want people to
know that.
Okay,
do you wear anything?
They don't want people to know that or people are just ignorant.
I think they don't even have to work hard at not having people know that.
I think we're just pretty ignorant.
Yeah,
I agree with that.
I think where there's also as time goes on,
people just getting more and more aware of the effect that your body has on your
mind.
These are the thing that was pretty separate,
like especially when I was growing up,
like I think people often look very intelligent.
People would look down upon physical exercise because they thought that physical
exercise was a vanity thing and then you had two schools of thought or twos,
two types of people.
You had people that were bringing people that we're concentrating on thinking
and they were concerned with the deeper,
more intellectual aspects of life and then yet people that were like more
physical people that were just trying to look good for the gym,
pumped their biceps up and you know,
and go fuck with my six pack.
But there were dummies.
Yeah.
I think now people realize that there is,
there's a connection between the mind and the body and also there's a discipline
aspect to exercise.
Nobody wants to exercise for the most part.
You want the results,
but it's difficult to get yourself to exert energy and that that discipline that
allows you to exert energy.
It's,
it's hard to like muster up and it is a part of your mental makeup to be able to
muster it up,
to be able to discipline yourself to work out on a regular basis actually
strengthens the mind because it,
it,
it exercises the discipline.
I don't think many people considered that in the past.
I don't think they thought of the discipline of,
you know,
activating your body,
like using your mind to activate your body that you're actually exercising
almost like a muscle.
And discipline is like a muscle.
And I think that the,
a lot of things correlate.
You know what I mean?
Like so many people are like fat and depressed.
Oh yeah.
But,
and they're depressed because they're fat and they're fat because they're not
working out and they're depressed because they're not working out.
Yeah.
Like w w one of the most natural cures for depression is like going for a walk
or going for a jog.
Just literally doing anything
other than sitting in one spot.
Well,
they've done studies that show that regular exercise is just as effective at
treating depression as pills cause ssrs.
Oh yeah.
I totally believe that.
That's another thing that I noticed back in Ohio.
It's like everybody's depressed and they're all just getting these pills and no
working out
and it's a place for pills.
There's a place for those pills for some,
I think some people have a legit imbalance.
Yeah,
but I think there's also like,
or I should fear is a perfect example.
Our,
he used to be on pills,
like he was like legitimately depressed,
got on pills,
got his life back in order,
like became a much happier person.
Then got off the pills like his life.
He got his life and track became much more successful.
Now he's just killing it out there in the world,
like doing fantastic with a stand up.
Like we were at the club last night,
the comics lounge in Melbourne,
there's all these Ari Shaffir posters on the wall there.
He was in town just a little while ago killing it and he's just doing great and
now now he's happy.
Like he doesn't need it.
He all says mushrooms.
Mushrooms helped him
do mushrooms help a lot.
Anytime I do mushrooms,
I come back and feel good for two or three months,
two,
three,
four months.
They should do it every two,
three,
four months then probably a good all the time.
It's true for some reason I doubt and I let the thing reload and live that
stress.
I feel like it almost probably sort of helps,
I don't know,
but maybe I'm wrong,
but I feel like it's like you make the muscles tense and then massage amount
rather than just get a massage.
But I probably should do them once every four months.
When I was young,
I used to think that like the whole idea of being enlightened,
uh,
being enlightened or gauge sheaving like a more balanced,
more relaxed view of the world.
I used to think it would fuck up my comedy and if I did that it would ruin me.
Like I would stop being funny because a lot of comedy is kind of mean.
Yeah.
You know,
and a lot of comedies like what you,
what you're creating with comedies shitting on something.
And I used to think,
well,
if I just achieved peace,
then I won't want to shit on things and if I don't want to shit on things and
I'll be shit out of luck as far as like my standup go,
so fuck this.
Then as I got older I realized that that's just a crutch.
Yeah,
it's definitely crossed my mind that like,
well I,
I,
I do want to do mushrooms to feel better,
but I don't want to do mushrooms because I want to be able to connect with that
audience that's in the room if I'm too far ahead of them.
I literally,
you know,
I think of everything that when it comes to my comedy,
I'm always trying to protect it.
Yeah.
If you were to Koombaya yeah,
you might,
you know,
you might lose your edge because your edge too is a lot of like you're,
you're a great roast writer and a lot of roast writing is being fucking mean.
Yeah.
And it's hard to do that if you're,
if you're all Koombaya by
out,
if it's true,
but it helps.
I mean,
it's crazy.
Like my favorite stuff is always the stuff that I write when I come back a week,
a week to three after those trips to the desert that we take.
Yeah.
You can write some amazing shit like post psychedelic experiences.
Add clears the gutters,
man.
Makes everything flow better.
Yeah.
I think the writing is,
uh,
I think there's all sorts of different states that you should write under.
I think you should write a little,
when you're drinking,
I think you should write a little sober.
You should write a little,
when you're high off pot,
you could ride,
she'd write post psychedelic writing while you're on.
Psychedelics was kind of pointless.
Like you could write to say things into a tape recorder maybe,
but sitting down trying to write things down while you're tripping.
Yeah.
And even then you forget what you felt like when you were taking the note.
So it's like just a code and you can't really crack it anyway,
even though the words are there.
It's hard to go back to that feeling of clarity that sometimes you see like I
know for a fact.
There's been times where I'm out in that desert looking up at the stars and all
of a sudden like I figure out the trick to everything.
You know that feeling clicks then where it's like,
oh,
oh shit,
I just did it.
I just beat the game.
But then you,
it just like can't exactly put your finger on what it was.
Cause the to describe those feelings that happen in words.
It's impossible.
The words haven't been created yet to describe what goes on in that zone.
Well,
describing DMT is like that,
right?
Like you're describing it,
describing a DMT experience.
You're just spinning your wheels.
Yeah.
It's wasting time.
I've read like my own descriptions of a DMT trip and I'm might be shut up.
Dot.
It sounds so stupid.
Yeah,
because the words,
they don't exist.
The reference points don't exist like you can.
There's no way you could possibly know what the fuck you're talking about.
You're saying something that you're,
you're using these noises to describe like,
you,
like you were describing some shit like we were at the airport.
Oh,
I should probably say we're,
we're not,
um,
we're not on the plane.
And I said that we were going to do one of these a plane and somewhere along the
line while we're flying,
I was like,
yeah,
fucking do it on the hotel room and probably be better.
Yeah.
You know,
I slept most of the time on the plane,
but when we were at the airport going through that security guy and you were
talking about the pope hats,
the guys at the Po paths you saw when you were doing DMT,
like I kind of can kind of get that.
Yeah.
You know,
like I kind of see,
but if I didn't,
if I've never done it and I heard that,
I'd be like,
what are you talking about?
Right.
Like I had no idea.
Oh,
great.
The,
the fucking gone.
Jesus doesn't like us talking about Po path.
You bring up pope pads,
the cathedral starts banging their bells.
Um,
but yeah,
no,
I,
I remember,
I think you said something about fractals or something or somebody did,
maybe it,
um,
somebody that we were with then I remember hearing that word and I didn't put,
I didn't even know what that really was at the time until afterwards.
Like,
oh yeah,
fractals,
like reposition,
like kaleidoscope,
like,
yeah.
And that's exactly what it was like.
It was like a Kaleida a kaleidoscope of pope.
Have you ever seen some of those?
Uh,
three d renditions,
like computer renditions of fractals.
[inaudible] it's pretty fucking amazing.
Like a,
there's a zoo and amazing fractal called the Mandelbrot set and there's this,
uh,
there's some three d renditions where they show,
you know,
the closer you get to these various points on this,
this,
uh,
this fractal,
the more the same patterns repeat themselves.
Like you looks like you're getting close to a small point,
but the,
as you get closer,
it just reveals a deeper and deeper level and layer of this fractal where it
just,
it's,
it's infinite.
It keeps going on and on and on and on.
And as you get closer,
it just shows you it's the same thing in a smaller form.
Then it goes on and on and on,
and that's,
that's the impression that you get when you do DMT,
that there's this like infinite series of fractals that are going on all around
you and that there's no end.
You can't find an end.
You just look,
the deeper you look,
the deeper it goes.
And that's sort of what they've found about the whole universe.
I mean,
they've,
the,
they believe that,
you know,
as you look deeper and deeper into life and you look deeper and deeper into the
cellular level,
deeply or deeper and deeper into the atomic level,
then you get into subatomic particles and you get into this weird world of space
where did,
it's mostly just empty air.
And then there's some atomic particles that are blinking in and out of
existence.
And then there's,
there's things that are,
they have things that they've observed,
but they called her in a super position,
which means they're both moving and still at the same time.
And it's like,
yeah.
And as,
as you go deeper and deeper into the subatomic level,
things become more and more like magic,
more and more like just science fiction and craziness.
Like most of what an atom is it just empty space and it's where,
which they're trying to understand it the deeper and deeper they go with this
kind of stuff.
But many people theorize that what we're seeing in the universe itself,
like when you look at the universe and you see like the empty space,
it's in the galaxies and space out in the,
the,
you know,
the infinite cosmos that what you're seeing sort of mirrors itself inside are
very Adams and that,
can you imagine if they just kept digging,
digging with a microscope and they kept going through everything and through
everything.
And at the very end of it all,
there was just l Ron Hubbard's face
and it was him all along.
I am God wants to mysterious ways.
What you imagine if we,
what we got deeper and deeper into sub atomic level and we found universes,
that's what would be the ultimate trip if we got so like if they figured out
some way.
I mean if you look at what they can observe today as opposed to work they could
observe a few hundred years ago,
it's no comparison.
They have so many,
so many new,
much more sensitive methods of detecting energy and detecting and recognizing
structures and Adams and all this different shit.
What if it got to the point where they could detect deeper and deeper and deeper
layers and they actually really did find that inside a atomic particles that as
you go deeper and deeper,
you can actually find completely independent universes that operate on a scale
so minute that we can't even comprehend.
But if you could,
could you got deeper and deeper into them.
You would find like little tiny miniature black holes,
a little miniature at galaxies,
miniature planets and the,
the,
the whole thing is fractal.
And as you went into them,
like they believe that inside every black hole,
they think that every galaxy is,
uh,
there's a supermassive black hole.
The center of that galaxy and that supermassive black holes is one half of 1% of
the mass of the entire galaxy.
So the larger the galaxy,
the,
the larger the black hole is,
and they theorize it.
If you go into that black hole,
you will find another universe.
So each galaxy has a black hole in it.
Inside each black hole is a totally different universe filled with hundreds of
billions of galaxies,
each with black holes in the center of them.
Each one of them has hundreds of billions of galaxies inside of it.
Have you go through that?
There's more universe is more black holes and it's,
that's the real fractal nature of the universe that every time you hit a galaxy,
which is it in our mind,
we can't even imagine how big a galaxy
generations from now,
what it feels like.
It's like generations,
tens and tens,
maybe a hundred generations from now,
they're going to be flying through these things in little machines.
We can't fathom it now,
but we're like the pirates that were coming over here on wooden ships compared
to what generations,
and I'm talking a lot of generations ahead of us.
They're going to be flying through it.
Look at who's going to be sports race from one black hold of the other.
Like,
I mean we are in the wrong age.
We were born too early.
No,
we're
born perfect.
This is a great time.
It was a great time.
Yeah.
You don't want to be like in the future there'll be no need for comedy.
Everybody's going to be reading minds will be fucked.
Right.
You know,
they're all be enlightened in.
They'll do be no the hypocrisy.
So no contradiction.
So like comedy won't won't exist.
If we achieve up to a new state of enlightenment where humor is out the window,
we would be fucked.
Like we're reaping the benefits of an unenlightened public.
Well,
that's like what,
what standup is like we're pointing out shit that everybody should be able to
see.
Right.
Or pointing out things that everybody should know and then we're mocking things
that existed.
A ridiculous,
well,
if people evolve past the state,
there are now,
they are now like if,
if you look at like primate behavior,
you look at the savagery of nature when just tooth and claw on animals is
struggling to survive.
And then you'd look at the more civilized nature of our culture today,
the best aspects when everything is working at its smoothest,
usually in small groups,
but in small groups,
in small communities,
you can find some pretty peaceful existences,
you know,
that will ultimately be the whole world.
And then it'll get more and more peaceful,
more and more civilized,
more,
more adapted,
more cultured,
more connected,
more enlightened to the point where mocking things like won't exist anymore.
There'll be nothing to mock.
People will be so advanced mentally that there will be no more of a need for
comedy.
So I think right now for you and I,
this is a perfect time.
If we're in the future and everything was all perfect,
enlightened,
we'd be fucked and it wouldn't be fun.
And now we're in this,
this,
we're in this golden stage where there's just enough retarded shit,
right?
Like this Paris thing,
there's just enough chaos in the world where it makes you appreciate all the,
the cool aspects of the world.
Like if everything was cool,
I don't think we'd appreciate the cool parts is much.
You think there's a way to combat these terrorists attacks?
Like you know like it seems like if you draw Muhammad like that they get really
upset,
right?
That that's like their big like oh no,
don't do that thing.
Like so like I don't know,
I'm just pitching here.
Like what if every time they did something like this as a defense mechanism,
like CNN just put out like the Mohammed cartoon.
Like if they just like they called in South Park South Park's guys and we're
like guys let's do this.
Let's bring in our nuclear warfare and you make a hilarious Mohammad thing.
Have him just getting whatever,
you know,
bud raped or whatever.
Like I don't know,
like something crazy.
Do you really think that would fix it and mocking it if as a defensive
mechanism,
if they kill people,
that's the only way.
Every listen terrorists,
it's me,
Prime Minister Tony Hinchcliffe from now on.
If you do an attack,
if somebody said this,
if you do an attack and you kill innocent people,
every innocent person that you kill,
it's going to be another two minutes or another five minutes of the Mohammed
cartoon.
That might be one of the dumbest ideas I've ever heard.
They hate the Mohamad things,
so don't you think there's a big difference from killing people and drawing
cartoons?
Like what does worse?
These terrorists don't
seem to think so though,
right?
Can only put all these people in Paris because of a cartoon.
They killed a few people that were doing those Charlie Hebdo cartoons.
Yeah.
I think the real problem is when people get their mind in a pattern,
you get your mind in some sort of a radical ideology like Islam or radical
Islam.
It's super difficult to get people out of that radical ideology.
It's very,
very difficult.
Very difficult to get them to rethink to,
to,
to change these patterns in their mind where they go.
Yeah.
Actually,
it doesn't make any sense to just go to some random death metal concert and gun
people down.
I can yell.
God is great.
Yeah.
It doesn't make sense.
It's crazy.
That's chaos,
right?
That,
that that is an evil thing to do and that doing this evil thing for religion,
like saying you're doing it for religion,
does it make any sense at all?
But in their mind it's justified.
Their mind is a holy war going on.
These people that are completely radicalized,
like in their mind,
this is a good thing to do in their mind.
This is like what you have to do to get back at the infidels and attack this
evil empire that's invading countries are supporting this or you know,
whatever.
Whatever crazy war is going on in the world as far as uh,
the ideologies as far as like invading certain holy lands and what's liquor
would isis is doing,
they're blowing up old monuments and there's so much crazy shit that's going on
in the world that's related to radical ideologies.
You'd have to figure out how to rewire their brains.
Can I tell you what another thing I think we should do?
I think we should take,
I think we should take guys on death row and put bombs on them and have them go
into the places.
But the terrorists,
you might be the worst foreign policy advisor ever.
I want to sit you down with all these five star generals that are in these
fucking smoky rooms plugging in the future.
What do you want to do?
Well,
I want to take Jared from subway
strapped bombs doing them and send them over to,
well,
why would he do that?
Uh,
I didn't think of that.
Why would Jared keep walking?
Why would he detonate?
I you,
is he going to know he's going to blow up?
He's not going to tell them
all right.
Maybe we put them in.
We'd take these guys and we put them in uh,
on the cars that are like controls or Google cars.
Drones.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There you go.
Yeah.
They just killed that Jihadi John Guy.
They killed that guy with a drone.
He's that guy that was a rapper who's a rapper in England and joined isis and
he's been killing people and be heading them.
Sure.
Allegedly,
you know there's the black helicopter squad that believed that this is all
bullshit.
There was a rapper and isis.
Yeah.
Then ally says,
oh Geez,
I'm going to get,
that's the thing that
I'll end up getting death threats for out of this.
You can't help yourself with that.
Kenyon puns.
Now when I hear a funny word and it's a right set up and I think there's just
one chance for,
the funny thing is I never do them on like I'm known for them but I never do
them on stage with my standup.
Like I would never do that.
That I love making them in person.
I just love comedy.
You know what I mean?
I'm terrible that impressions but God did,
they crack me up.
Like there's nothing that I don't love about comedy and I,
a lot of comedians are like,
Oh fuck upon.
You know,
I hate puns but it's like
you liked puns even though you don't use them on stage.
Right?
Like,
and I think everybody does.
I think there's a war on puns,
right?
Oh Lauren pond.
Cause everybody wants to complain about puns,
but it's like everybody laughs so hard,
like a good pun hits harder than almost any.
I laugh at puns.
I laugh at your puns cause they're so ridiculous.
But it's almost like a reluctant laugh.
Like oh you son of a bitch.
Yeah.
But sometimes they're like,
you know Jed I punks,
you know and I mean that are just like how though?
Fuck did you think of that that quick.
Will you like take pride in grabbing them as quickly as they can?
Like the ponds come out of the event?
Yeah.
And you just grasp it as quick as you can.
Right.
My brain does not think in ponds at all.
It's definitely a different muscle.
Like it's hard for me to think of a pun and be intellectual at the same time.
Like it's definitely like,
it's like a that thing where like rubbing your head and your stomach at the same
time but going different directions.
Yeah.
People can't do it because I have,
I have,
I,
I've noticed that because you have to like listen to do that thing and you sort
of have to be add at the same time to do a pun.
Is it,
since this isn't a video podcast,
that's how you chose trying to do the hand on the head.
I did
get the of the rubbing my head in two different directions and my stomach to get
dirty.
I go back and forth and back and forth.
Yeah.
It's a different muscle.
The pine muscles definitely a different muscle.
Yeah.
But it's also like a different comedic instantly we were talking about guys who
get trapped in certain patterns of comedy.
Like you get trapped in an act.
I'm like,
all you do is like this style of comedy.
And then when that,
when you have that sort of trap,
um,
you can,
you can get it kind of kind of fuck you out.
We were talking about guys who like only do like evil type comedy or the only do
this type calm or they only have like they have a,
an act they do where it's a persona they adopt.
Right.
Like a Larry the cable guy or an emo Phillips or something like that.
Like a one liner guy.
Yeah.
Go slow and like,
yeah.
And you get stuck in those are like when,
when it's done right.
It's awesome.
Yeah.
Like,
like a Steven ride or something like that or uh,
you know,
the best one ever and I'm,
I think was Mitch Hedberg was the best.
Yeah.
Because he was so prolific.
Like his mind worked in that way.
Like his style of comedy worked in these nonsequitor one liners where he could
just one after another.
I have these like totally unrelated things.
Unbelievable.
You know,
I was thinking of him,
I just told you about that Amy Winehouse documentary that blew my mind to shreds
and I was thinking about him during it because heroin,
heroin and the art,
the Amy wine that she was always like very genuine,
like a real artist and always wrote all only your own stuff and like you can
tell like through her work,
like it was really actually amazing and they show you to this documentary and
then something happens.
She was always a heavy drinker,
always quite the party or like a rock star,
you know what I mean?
But then when she started doing heroin,
because this guy that she was with was into heroin,
the lyrics in the songs were a whole nother level.
I mean we've seen it a bunch of times but I mean it really went to another level
and it made me think of Mitch Hedberg because there's something with that drug
or I mean,
I mean I'm not taking anything away from Mitch cause he's the one that did it,
but it just can't be coincidence that these people on heroin are able to tap
into some super,
super mechanism.
Yeah.
Because who would have guessed that anybody would come out better than Stephen
Right at that thing.
Like you watch Steven Wright and 10 minutes in,
I'm like how is he going to fill an hour with this?
It seems impossible.
And then I agree with you completely that Mitch came in over the top and how's
that possible?
How could Mitch Hedberg not just the Steven Wright and go,
ah,
I've got to figure out something different to do cause there was no way I'm
going to be able to do that better than that guy.
Right.
I mean Steven Wright was the man,
but my goodness,
if he didn't do it and there's something about those jokes,
if you just look at him just written out,
like sometimes I'll see like a meme with Mitch Hedberg on it and I'll end up
staring at that.
And I'm not a meme guy at all,
but I'll end up staring at that little tiny thing,
which were all the original tweets by the way.
Mitch.
Mitch Hedberg was the original Twitter guy.
Yeah.
I mean and like
think of that banana joke that I love so much.
Which one is that?
Um,
it goes,
somebody asked me if I want a frozen banana.
I said no,
but I want her regular banana later.
So yes,
it's like a perfect,
it's a perfect Twitter joke,
but it's so ridiculous.
It's also a joke that if you looked at it on paper,
maybe it wouldn't be a good Twitter joke unless you knew Mitch Hedberg voice.
Maybe then it would be a good Twitter joke cause you knew how he does.
Joe,
I still think it'd be great on Twitter,
but that's a,
that is another thing.
You have a great point there is like when you factor in his timing and beats,
which also I think plays into the heroin thing.
You look at all the Rock Stars and all that and most of them I it's seeming more
like,
I feel like it's more of like an acoustic type of drug,
if that makes sense to me.
Like more like nirvana and wine house who was very jazzy,
you know those types of towns and I just feel like there's a direct crossover.
I feel like Hedberg really was like God was he dialed in cause that voice and
that timing,
really timing and pacing is the trick.
He could have had any accent in any voice.
You know when you decide to start that next line after a period like in between
spaces is so important in comedy.
I think like people really don't know that.
I think they think that you could say joking anyway,
but it's really like,
you know,
there's just guys like look at Joey Diaz and Sebastian Maniscalco mean everybody
really.
It's all done to timing,
but sometimes you can really see it
summarizing what you're saying.
Is that they find their,
their voice,
they find their rhythm and then their comedy.
Like even though like maybe you and I would look at it on paper,
the premise on paper and go,
how is that fucking funny?
But like Sebastian has such a way with being Sebastian that he makes things
right.
It's hard to figure out like what is the unfathered,
what is the ungraspable quality of what he's talking about that's uniquely funny
in his voice.
Right.
You find that whatever it is.
Yeah,
that's through practice.
Just like,
I mean,
like if you talking about,
since we're talking about the on paper thing,
like you said the Hedberg thing and like that's pretty funny on paper,
but now if you really like broke down,
like if you were reading a Joey Diaz,
like on paper,
what's up?
You cock suckers.
Yeah.
It's like
you gotta eat the Yolk,
you got eat,
you can eat the lines,
eat the yolk.
You cannot eat the whites.
Like,
it's like it wouldn't make,
it wouldn't be funny at all on paper,
but you give him the,
you've gotta,
Ooh,
I'm not fucking,
you know what I mean?
It's so passionate and it's all,
it's all timing there.
I mean,
and so when there is a something on paper,
when he does hit one of those written things,
it's just boom.
Isn't
that also a weird thing about comedy is like you've got to figure out what is
funny in your mind.
Like how was it funny through your voice and the only way you figure that out is
by doing comedy over and over and over and over and over and over and over
again.
Yeah.
You got to get to this point where kind of makes sense to you,
but you,
you figure out how to do it.
That's,
that's so hard to figure.
Like you could never look at a guy like Mitch Hedberg before he ever did stand
up and go,
I know what you should do.
Like you can't write,
you'll never get it.
You'll never get it like that.
It is not like anything else you,
it has to be this unique combination of his personality,
his insight,
his timing,
his experience on stage and his willingness to sit down and write shit out as
much as possible.
Like his act is all writing.
It's all writing.
Whereas like a guy like Sebastian,
it's all performing.
It's all things there,
you know,
both very funny,
but it's figuring out what,
what is about the way you're sitting around looking at the world?
How is it funny coming out of your head?
Yeah,
it's interesting.
The more and more that I do this,
the more and more that I do stand up and it's been,
uh,
in May,
it'll be nine years.
Um,
the more and more that I do at the more and more that my newest material,
my most recent stuff is always the best stuff.
And I'm writing,
I'm not writing as much as I was years ago because I'm just writing more good
stuff,
if that makes sense.
I'm writing less extra stuff and like I guess I'm writing the same amount of
stuff,
but I'm having more good stuff because I'm writing more in that voice.
I'm starting to figure out what that is.
Yeah.
Even down to like the physicalities for example that I do,
cause I barely move on stage.
I'm pretty stabilized and sort of pretty stationary.
Right?
Huh.
Yeah,
very stationary.
Sometimes I'll tuck my arm behind my back.
Maybe I'll switch my shoulder levels to the left to the right to the middle.
I'll move that around a little bit.
But I'm very station at an ordinarily stationary I feel like and however,
you know,
one of the things that I do is sometimes I'll rattle off things and I'll count
on my fingers and I'll point some way.
Just nothing too crazy.
But little things.
And those are always,
you know,
when I use that device,
lovely.
It has to work.
So I have their brains sort of train now and it's just something that happened
naturally because I don't really talk with my hands a lot and stuff.
But when I do talk with my hands,
I want it to be like thunder.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Have you ever noticed that Joey never takes a mic out of his down?
It's amazing.
He puts them like in the stem,
the leaves in the stand and I think part of that is you want both of his hands
free because he talks with his hands so much.
Yeah.
He doesn't want to be trapped holding that microphone.
And it is physical stuff like involves the mic stand,
like you'll hang onto the mic stand during his physical stuff.
Yeah.
I love it.
And when he lifts it up and slams it down real quick,
it's just like even know he's killed one,
if that sounds okay.
He's kind of always done that too.
He's always for the longest time at least not taking the Mick out of the stand.
Yeah.
I've always,
I always have a respected that tremendously.
I always take the Mick out of the stand,
but I love,
love,
love the fact that,
you know,
that's that it's possible to just have that kind of,
did Rodney take the my Johnstown.
I don't think so.
No,
I can't picture him holding a microphone,
Huh?
Yeah,
I kind of like see like a similarity there.
You know,
using the hands.
Joey did [inaudible]
but everybody else does like you do you take it out Stan?
I do already.
Does Dunkin does.
We all have our own way.
Yeah.
If I had to do a whole set with the mic in the stand,
I'd feel so weird.
Yeah.
I always think it's weird like I didn't notice this until recently,
but like there's a lot of those late nights sets.
They don't have a microphone or at all.
I'm like,
have you ever done any of those had to go no hands?
I don't think so.
Maybe I'll have you keep the mic and the mic stand or no,
you take them on trauma.
I take it out but I'm trying to think.
Yeah.
Have I ever done that?
Have I ever done a late night show or I didn't use a mic?
I don't know.
That's a good if I did it was so long ago,
but
I dunno what I do.
I mean what am I going to do?
Stand there with my hands on my hips and like just like arms crossed.
You can't do that.
Like oh,
hello everybody.
Yeah,
we'll also,
you can't modulate your voice in the microphone the way you can when you're
holding a microphone or if it's in a stand,
like you could like talk closer to it to get louder.
You pull away to get softer.
You can modulate,
you can change it and adjust it on the fly.
Yeah.
Do you ever see a Chris Titus?
You still,
I don't know if he still does it,
but he has one of them Bobby Brown setups where he's like a teleconference sir.
That's a little little microphone that comes,
get a like a headset and the microphone comes down to the corner of his mouth
and he talks like that shit creeps me out.
That's a weird choice.
Yeah.
So weird choice for a comedy club.
I mean,
why would you want to have the same headset is like a ted talks are like,
yeah.
You know,
it's just to like tell a telecommunication.
Well his thing is different.
Like his style of comedy is different.
He started comedy is more like a performance piece,
you know,
everything is like tight.
Like he told me,
I asked him like how he writes and he writes all of it out before he ever does
it.
He has like a theme,
like this is his theme and he writes his whole set.
He writes this theme out and then he performs it almost like a one man show more
than like a standup comedy show.
And maybe having one of those headsets makes people feel like they're at a
different sort of thing.
Like,
oh,
he doesn't even have a microphone in his hand.
Like a regular comedian.
He's got this whole thing where he's got a little headset on with a loop that
comes down by his face and I see that little loop and oh and it might maybe kind
of puts you in a different mindset as a person watching it.
I'm watching a theatrical presentation as much as I'm watching stand up.
Yeah,
I know that when I see that headset to grab the remote and change the channel,
that's the headset tells me psychologically.
What do you think?
Do you think pretentious,
like w w the yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh yeah,
totally.
I think we're like,
whoa,
who's trying to like reinvent you know you,
you,
I think there's something so cool about taking the Mick out of the mic stand the
same way Eddie Murphy did and raw and Richard Pryor live on the sunset strip and
all that stuff.
That's a magic.
That's what's amazing that Mike and that Mike stand is all we need that stool.
That is it.
Maybe there's a bottle of water out there.
Maybe there's a towel.
Maybe there's nuts about it and that's it and that's what I love about it.
You take that away.
Then you have the same stage that's there in the middle of the day when no
crowds there,
there's no magic.
I always loved that.
Feel that vibe.
I even like sound check sound checks.
Give me the chills when there's nobody out there and you just see the mic and
the mic stand that's going to be used that night.
Like that instrument of death just standing there.
But an empty stage is sorta just sad to me and MTM and do.
Then he just has the stool or something like,
I don't even know.
It's just not into that.
It seems like the kind of guy that would up like wacky backgrounds two and
especially
like maybe his name and giant block letter.
Right.
And like memories from his childhood or back there and though kid pictures.
Oh No.
And then he moves over towards that section where he's talking about certain
things.
Yeah.
Well when you have that headset on,
I expect you to be giving some sort of a motivational Anthony Robbins type
speech.
Right.
How do I invigorated?
Yeah,
my staff.
How do I get my employees as enthusiastic as I am?
Well,
that's a good question.
You pacing.
Yeah.
Right.
I didn't even know.
I don't know anything about Christopher Titus.
That's what's crazy.
It's like I've made friends with so many comedians and worked with so many
people and met in this and that.
I don't know anything about them and I attribute a lot of that to the headset
style that he has.
I think we come from two totally different sides of the spectrum.
I'm just guessing.
I don't even know what he talks about or anything about him,
but I'm guessing him and I are like two different schools.
I don't know.
You'd probably have to go see him.
I haven't seen him live in a long fucking time.
I feel like Gallagher used one of those,
right?
I think so.
Yeah.
He had to smashing shit with a watermelon with a hammer,
rather.
If you're using that giant sledge hammer,
you have two hands on a sledge hammer.
You have to have a headset.
Right?
Yeah.
I wonder if he had wires because when he was doing it,
man.
Yeah.
Dean del Ray was telling me about the guy who invented the wireless headset or
the guy who invented a wireless microphone.
He had him on his podcast and Dean knows the guy and apparently it took the guy
like a decade or more to figure out how to do it right.
Do having still,
almost never right.
I think he should sell good.
Back to the drawing board on.
It always gives out.
I hate wireless mikes.
They're just not as much fun as the ones with chords.
Dame,
they work pretty flawlessly.
I had to do one today.
I use one today at the Wayans that wasn't wireless,
Mike.
Yeah,
but those are
really,
that's a,
that's a big,
big top.
You're at the top level of production.
They're like,
they end plus that Mike,
they have enough battery in that thing.
And the thing you did wasn't that long,
you know,
and they have that all juiced up with a double backup and five,
they have one shot at it.
Every channel
when we're doing a six hour show,
they changed my battery for my,
uh,
my battery pack because I have a wireless battery pack.
I have a wireless,
um,
Mike that is in my ear.
So when I am,
I'm going onto the,
uh,
into the octagon.
I have a backup,
like a,
um,
a,
a battery that's in the microphone.
And then I also have batteries that are in the receiver where there's an
earpiece so the production can talk into my ear.
Like they'll say things like,
uh,
we have a replay for you if you want to go to that,
let us know or we'll follow your lead.
They'll say things like that.
Like maybe I'm talking to someone about something particularly interesting that
happened during the fight and uh,
they'll tell me like we're about to show it.
Or like a lot of times fighters are rambling about their sponsors and thanking
all are fucking Moses or whatever.
They'll like say to cut them off,
cut them off,
which I can only do so much I kind of right.
But those batteries,
they changed those batteries at least once during the course of the UFC.
Like they put a freshman at the beginning and it change it halfway through.
Yeah.
There's just simply never as many problems with wires is there are with
wireless.
Yeah.
Except the comedy store though.
The microphone the other day was fucking wire was fallen out.
That's awesome.
The comedy store once every few months that happens cause so many comedians are
dropping the Mike and trying to yeah.
Trying to use it as a prop and yeah,
it's craziness there.
People are so desperate.
Well,
it's also that that Mike gets used by all the open miker is doing potluck too.
So get used by,
you know,
20 people that have maybe never even held a micro for every Monday,
you know?
Where were you saying though about the guy that invented the wireless?
Oh,
Dean del Ray had him on his podcast and dean was explaining to me how long this
guy worked to develop that and how fucking rich this guy is now.
This guy owns like the most expensive house in San Francisco.
He has some crazy castle that he built just from the money that he made from the
wireless Mike and yeah,
I will let dean explain it.
I wish I could remember if you just Google Dean del Rey's,
let there be rock or let there be talk that,
that's his podcast,
right?
He's got an episode somewhere in there where he talks to the guy who invented
the wireless Mike and the guy explains it,
but what a freak out that is.
Like I figured out how to make a frequency that you can tune into in a building.
I think you said the rolling stones were the first ones to use it,
but then once they started using it,
everybody wanted to use like,
wait,
what?
Like the guitar is not connected to wires.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
You know,
and then they have to have a different frequency obviously for the guitar than
they do for the other shit that's going on.
Wow.
A few different frequencies that are floating around the air.
I like radio signals.
I like her wires,
man.
I think it gives us a feeling of stability and connection and like,
I don't know,
there's something about losing the particles of art in the air.
That's just seems risky to me.
It really does.
Like,
I mean there's just so few problems with the wired mic in this,
that on off switch and there's a button there and sometimes when you're
performing you feel it against your thumb.
Like Whoa,
that's close and you've got to like turn it.
That's like one more problem that we need up there.
Yeah.
That is just like a little,
you know,
sometimes it is off by the way,
cause I go out there first sometimes and every once in awhile there's nothing
crazier than you on this side.
Mike on Melbourne card,
what the fuck is up?
And the place just goes,
yeah,
yeah.
And You bring me up the Golden Pony,
Tony Hinchcliffe it
and I walk up and then it's like a 1520 second walk to the mic sometimes in
these big venues and you grabbed the mic and you're like,
what's up Melbourne?
And you realize that the flowers and not on and then you have to hit the button.
Dude,
it happens like five or 10% of the time.
I don't make a deal about it or complain about it,
but when there's a wireless mic,
five to 10% of the time,
that's the ratio I'm getting for this.
There's a problem.
Normally they're not turned on in the beginning.
Like it's like the easiest thing that everybody forgets to do and then I'm
stuck.
I know how to turn all those on.
By the way from that,
I never took,
I never owned one of these mikes.
I took her class.
You might end up finding out where every button is on everything like yeah.
With,
with,
with three,
four,
5,000 people watching and they don't even realize,
they're like,
oh,
he's taking his time saying hello to us.
It's like,
no,
I already tried.
Well they used to be the old ones had the antennas in the bottom and if you got
too close to the antenna would cut off.
I'll give you to hold it too close to the bottom.
They'd tell me,
even in the early days of the UFC when I would do post fight interviews,
don't grab the bottom of the Mike you had to grab like or towards the top.
And I would grab it like with my index finger and my,
um,
my thumb and sort of let my other fingers relaxed that I want to grip it too
tight at the bottom because I worried that it would cut off the signal somehow.
Like if you grab it low,
like a fight or sometimes they would take the mic from me or are they would hold
onto the mic as well and they would touch the bottom of it.
It would cut off the signal.
Yeah,
they're,
they're more problematic.
It's something you could use cords to,
you know,
use them as props as part of like the cord.
Yeah.
Like I had a a bit that I used to do about having a girl jerk you off.
So I tried to brush your teeth with your left hand.
Like they don't,
they don't have the type of coordination that's developed over years and years
of jerking off.
Right.
You know,
like when a girl says a,
I'll just do it with my hand.
Like what would make you think that you could possibly be as good at that as me?
Right.
And I would do this bit or I would hold the cord with my left hand and I'd be
jerking it off like a girl with a tired arm.
Like,
oh my God,
I have to switch hands.
And like I needed the cord if I didn't have the cord.
It wouldn't work as well.
Yeah.
I need a physical thing in my hand that I was tugging on.
It made more sense then I was just,
if I was doing it,
the air,
the bit would be like 10% less effective.
And plus I feel like there's just something fun,
especially when we're doing like big theaters and big stages.
There's something fun about that whip.
You know what I mean?
Like just like getting out of the way.
Cause I think it sort of tells the audience,
I'm going to get this out of the way cause I've stuffed to do,
I've stuffed to share with you.
You know what I mean?
Like get this shit and like moving it.
I feel like that's all sort of like training the audience to sort of be like,
oh he knows what he's doing.
You know what I mean?
Like he's getting that out of the way.
Something's about to happen.
Like I dunno,
I feel like there's something,
I'm just pro cord all the way.
How many clubs have you performed at in New York City?
Um,
pretty much all of them.
Have you ever noticed that?
Like a lot of the clubs in New York in particular,
they have really small stages,
really small.
The craziest was Caroline's.
Caroline's would have two different stages.
They'd have the regular stage and then you have to sell out stage where they
would take the wings off the side and you would be in a sold out room of 300
people and they would be fucking on top of you.
I mean literally they could touch your Dick,
they could reach out and just touch you.
You're so close to the audience.
Their tables are so small and everybody's stuffed in there.
And I think that that style of calm,
like there's a certain type of intimacy in those clubs,
like a stand up New York is like that.
There's a certain type of intimacy in those clubs because you can't move around
very much.
You can't get very physical and you almost have to talk to the audience.
You almost have to address them.
Right.
Cause they're right in front of you.
Yeah.
It's so small.
Like I don't think people realize when they're watching.
Like Louie how small that stages at the cellar.
Oh,
it's tiny.
There's enough in there.
It's like a shoe box.
Yeah.
It's like really,
really,
really crazy small where it's like,
um,
even the belly room's bigger than that.
Oh yeah.
Oh definitely.
Yeah.
Ever.
Oh ours arms bigger than that.
Oh yeah.
I think the ors the perfect room.
I think the original room at the comedy store is literally the private room.
I think Bella Room almost might be too small,
but it's a good,
it's a good proving ground.
It's a good place to fuck around.
It's a good room to get good for the LR.
Yeah.
And then the main room was like the big show.
But the main room still,
if I would take a sold out hot.
Oh our crowd over a sold out main room crowd.
Yeah.
Cause it's our wallets harder.
It's more fun to kill him.
I'm telling you,
I had this set the other night and it's because of Joey Diaz Cause Joey Diaz
made them believe that miracles can happen.
So what happened?
Joey d is made this audience think that they were at the greatest thing ever.
And I was on,
I was there too.
I was in the back of the room watching him.
My hands hurting from clapping in a fucking pumped me up man.
And I had more fun in the,
or the other day at the comedy store.
They should,
you know,
I feel like it's not supposed to be that way.
I've should have had more fun in Atlanta,
headlining my own shows or like,
you know,
at odd ball or whatever.
But it's like there's something about that or it's probably cause it's the first
place I ever went up.
Well I forgot what it was like when I was not there for seven years.
I forgot I didn't in the kind of new,
there's something cool about it,
but going back like when I want what's,
it's been a year now since I've been back,
because I went back last November and when I went back I was like,
whoa,
this place is crazy.
I forgot,
I forgot.
There's like a unique feeling in that room because that was Ciro's nightclub and
because of how many people died there and how much crazy shit has gone on that
room.
Think about how much performing has been in that building.
Oh yeah.
There's nothing like it anywhere because it's been every day of the year from
nine till two in the morning.
Every day of the year.
Yeah.
Like unless there's some crazy thing that's going on,
they only closed for one day after that shooting.
Yeah.
And even,
oh,
I guess they stopped that show.
It happened.
Yeah.
But I mean,
Christmas,
new years,
Hanukkah,
those are big days.
Shashauna big days for them.
Every day,
every day,
seven days a week during 65 days a year.
And so like he used to call it the home from misfit toys,
the island of misfit toys is,
she used to call it.
I think about that a lot.
You know,
we were just talking about the hauntings last night at the comedy store and
yeah,
I think that it could have to do with all the people that have gotten killed
there,
but I think there's also something to be said about that being a building in
which every night there's this burst of energy for five or six hours and then
back down to complete silence to where you can hear a roach on the other side of
the building walking across the main room stage.
You know what I mean?
Like it gets so quiet there and then what,
16 hours later,
blah,
blah.
Every room filled to the gullets with human beings for five or six hours and
then yeah,
boom.
Like that doesn't happen anywhere.
You know what I mean?
Like yeah,
that fucking gone again.
Yeah.
Ding Dong,
Ding,
Ding Dong.
It's a shitty non melodic tune to hear that.
Yeah.
The Easter really like fucking music used to suck.
Oh they add or these six church bells.
You know,
what's amazing is that they figured out how to write music down and you could
recreate it like Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
Like they figured out how to write that down and you could,
you look at sheet music,
I can't read,
but people who can read it,
they look at that and they can perform something that was written down way
before things were ever recorded.
Like music was ever,
like,
they didn't figure out how to record music until like,
what was it,
like the 18 hundreds or the 19 whatever they figured out the first photographic
record.
It's probably like the early 19 hundreds or the late 18 hundreds,
whatever the fuck it was.
Whenever they figured out how to record an album,
you know,
uh,
on wax.
Think about how long they wrote stuff down that you could recreate.
Like you couldn't recreate like songs,
like as far as like how someone could sing.
Like if you think about the difference between the way Amy Winehouse sayings and
the way,
you know,
fill in the blank,
you know?
Yeah.
Any other,
you know,
Barbara Streisand sings or Risa Franklin sings,
we looked at Aretha Franklin.
Like how could you ever recreate that on paper where you can understand,
we've got to say to me,
you never could ever,
you know,
he never nail James Brown.
Oh,
get up,
get on up.
You can never figure out how to relay that to people without them actually
hearing it makes you wonder what we missed.
Oh yeah.
Singing and all that stuff.
We know.
That's,
uh,
one of the things,
I'm listening to this Dan Dan Carlin hardcore history podcast and it's a part of
it.
It's about Hurghada at us and how,
uh,
Herata just the way he would write history was so theatrical and so there was so
much flavor to the way he wrote things that they think that part of it was what
he wrote was meant to be performed.
That it was,
it was not just a written thing that was meant to be read,
but it was meant to be performed in like these theatrical presentations.
And that's how they used to relay history,
which was why it had so much flavor to it.
It like,
it was designed to rope people in that room watching it.
It would probably fucked up on homemade wine and you know,
yeah.
And those amphitheaters,
those,
those places that they had developed or they would have like a flat surface on
the ground in this,
these like tiered stairs all around them.
And they would have to project their words.
Like all that style of acting was all based on having to project so that people
could hear you.
That's sort of flavored how early acting was a lot of early acting was very over
the top.
Yeah.
And a big part of that was because they had to hear you in the back.
The room
didn't have microphones.
Yeah.
And now a lot of the best stuff is the opposite.
Like I feel like a lot of my favorite actors are like very,
very,
very chill.
Very,
very mellow.
Oh yeah.
Well you think about what you can get done with like a quiet voice now that you
could never do before.
Yeah.
You know,
with the smoldering,
which you could do now
in the d like you can really see their face and the way that they,
if they're upset or they're sad or anything.
And now acting I feel like has been,
you know,
so amplified.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's,
it's really interesting what they've been able to do as far as broadcasting and
recording people's movements and people's talking and well,
even in like martial arts,
like we're going to go see the UFC tomorrow.
I'll tell you,
man,
when I was young,
like watching people much better than me fight and watching them kick and
watching them perform techniques made me understand how to do them correctly
because I could watch them.
But you had to be around these guys to wash them.
Like when I was a kid,
I used to study tapes at the time was like VHS tapes,
but it was like the whole,
one of the first times that people had VHS tapes to study was in the 80s because
before that you had to have like a projector.
You had to get like a projection and like Mike Tyson used to watch old films at
custom models house.
He would go down,
he would operate one of those real to real projectors and watch old films of
people fighting and he learned from their movements like how to mimic and and
how to imitate those movements and how to learn from those movements.
And now you can just go to youtube.
You can find something like fighters today in the UFC to have such a massive
advantage of like being able to mirror and imitate and,
and sort of recreate the movements of like great fighters.
Cause you could see how they do it.
You could watch every Anderson Silva fight that he ever had in the UFC.
Anybody could watch him.
Yeah.
And you could see what he was able to do and how he moved.
It almost seems like we're at the point almost where like,
I don't know,
decades from now,
fighters will be able to like spar 3-d with their opponent coming up that
they're actually going against in the octagon.
Oh yeah,
definitely.
You know that they're going to get their real effects in real moves.
Like when they do the kicks,
the angles that you could just practice with that stuff and can't hollowed
grounds.
Yeah,
you'll have holograms.
Maybe you could wear a suit and when that person hits you in the Hologram,
like you'll feel some sort of an impact,
like not to the point where it will hurt,
but you'll be aware of where that when they connected on you.
Yeah,
and maybe when they connect on you,
like they're holographic image will respond as if they actually hit you.
Like they won't kick through you.
They'll kick up into the point where it touches you and you'll feel it on your
chest like you'll have some service suit on.
That's totally within the realm of possibility for the future when technology
advances.
Yeah,
virtual reality to men,
virtual reality is going to be so fascinating what they're going to be able to
do with movies.
You're going to be able to watch three d movies where you put a virtual reality
headset on and you're going to be immersed in the movie.
You'll be able to go through like a crime scene and look down at the body and
looked down at the person is trying to cover up the evidence and look,
look,
look out the window and see the cops pull up on their holy shit.
You're going to like be a part in the,
in the actual movie itself.
Yeah.
All these different ways to experience it.
Instead of being able to experience a movie in a flat sort of a two dimensional
way where you're forced to watch the scene as it director and laid it out,
you're going to be able to change and alter the senior yourself by your own
perspective.
You could just tied to stand on a chair in the scene,
you know,
and look at it from up above or get down on your knees and like look down at the
body,
looked down at the murder weapon or look down at the grass.
These people are playing in.
You're going to be able to manipulate your perspective and it'll change how you
enjoy a film.
Yeah.
It makes me want to start writing one like that.
Yeah man.
I like that thing.
You just start it like it's like
you know it on this.
Yeah,
well like a three dimensional game.
Like if you play a game like quake or unreal or you know some,
some three d shooter or you're going down these hallways,
you can pause at any time and look at the ground,
look at the walls and it becomes like an interactive thing and instead of,
and it's still obviously a work of art.
It's still,
when you're playing a game,
like it was not a,
if it's not an interactive game or if it's not rather a multiplayer game where
you're playing against another person,
if it's just you versus the computer,
you're,
you're still choosing how to approach it and how to interface with the game.
You could pause if you like,
you could stop and not move forward or you can run or you could go laughter.
You go right.
Like you choose and you're choosing to how you interact with this piece of art.
Like a video game is really a piece of art.
You're kind of choosing how you connect to it,
you know?
I think that's,
that's very likely going to be the way we experience movies.
Like you gotta be able to choose how you interact with it,
but then the problem with that is then it won't be like a film won't be
something that you really necessarily would enjoy watching it with other people.
Right?
Like at a movie theater.
Yeah.
It's going to be so different if you have a virtual reality headset on.
It's
true,
but I think watching the lease of people's way overrated.
Yeah.
When's the last time you went to a movie theater by yourself?
I bet it's been a while,
right?
Long time.
I never even thought about it again.
Maybe it's just a Midwest thing where it's like,
yeah,
I'm be by yourself.
Like I feel like that freak crazy.
Yeah,
exactly.
What are you gonna?
What are you a school shooter?
You don't go on a movie by yourself,
but man,
when there's any know,
I love my girlfriend.
She's amazing and she loves movies and we'd go and we see movies.
Is there something about going by yourself and you just have both armrests and
there's just no distractions touching you and asking you a question.
When's the last time somebody whispered something in your ear at the movie
theater and you said,
thank you for that in from like,
I'm really grateful for that information.
I wouldn't have known that or notice that and you're not,
you know,
a movie is supposed to like,
you're supposed to have your own take on it.
You know what I mean?
Like Quentin Tarantino said with pulp fiction that he wanted everybody that saw
that movie to have it,
to have seen a different movie,
to think that something else happened and miss apart and like have everybody
almost have like a different DNA for that movie.
Like that he didn't want to people to see the same thing and it makes sense
completely that,
that,
that for that movie.
Um,
and like,
um,
uh,
I don't even like anybody else in the movie theater,
not to mention somebody next to me.
The worst is people talking.
Well,
the worst to me,
I mean,
I hate talking.
That's way out of line.
But there's something about putting your feet on the chair in front of you.
You only do that if that chair's empty.
Right?
Somebody sitting,
sending that chair in front of you can't put your feet on.
It's like the same thing with an airplane.
So do you do,
you're an asshole.
There's some people that do put their feet on other people's chairs.
Yeah.
And it's super rude.
Well you can feel that in a movie theater.
They give you that two inch push that you know to where you could sorta like
lean back.
But so you feel it every time,
like big times.
Then you're watching a movie and shit serious and all of a sudden now you're
thinking about what kind of shoes the person behind you is wearing or like if
they're even wearing shoes and this and that and how out of line that is to do
that at a movie theater.
Like it's so out of line.
And by the way,
popcorn.
How did that become the thing at the movie theater?
I know it sounds like a hacky like premise,
but how did that become the theater food cause delicious and it's a good snack.
It's a good snack.
I Dunno if I give it delicious
with butter and salt.
Yeah.
I mean the first few bites they can get you with that dude.
Popcorns only good for about 10 bites and then it's just a workout and it's
there
and it's the loudest thing out of everything.
It's not the lab.
It is loud.
Yeah.
Crunch crunch so loud and you guys not as chips and every time somebody opens
the door you can hear it popping in the lobby too.
Like it's like loud to make.
It's allowed to eat.
You can hear it when people drop it.
You can eat.
Some of you heard it pop in the lobby.
Where are you going to the movie?
The new Beverly cinema on Beverly and Labrea.
Quentin Tarantino's theater.
They show like oil westerns.
Oh,
do you go there dude?
I watch the good,
the bad,
the ugly.
A few weeks ago.
Really with the crowd going crazy.
Crazy dude.
We need to go laughing at the funny scenes,
gasping at the ones like they show real movies.
October,
they just had Halloween,
they showed like beetle juice night of the living dead.
Like cool newbies chips would be worse though,
wouldn't they?
Yeah,
that'd be the worst.
Yeah.
And the bag of chips here,
right.
Chips would be terrible.
Shitty fucking church.
Yeah.
Keeps te te letting us think.
It's like a dog next door.
There's a guy named Frank Center.
Really?
It was a funny comic from Boston.
He used to,
he was in the Sopranos.
He had a scene as probably as a bartender,
his promise.
And he had this bit about a dog barking next door.
Right when you think it's gonna stop,
like Blah,
blah,
blah blah.
[inaudible]
Marc by Marc.
My mark.
Okay.
Like right when you would think it would stop
mark,
Barack Obama,
mark again.
That,
that it's like this fucking stupid church.
Yeah.
Some asshole is next door.
Just climbing on those bells.
Yeah.
Some hunchback,
some freak.
Um,
did you hear about what's going on with Quentin Tarantino where the cops are
boycotting him?
Yeah.
They don't want to work as movies cause he called them killers.
Kind of interesting.
Yeah.
Well I'm pretty sure,
uh,
I'm pretty sure that uh,
you know,
first of all they're drawing more attention to it then would have been had they
not boycotted his movies.
Yeah.
They wouldn't be talking about Quentin Tarantino doing that.
The whole,
the only thing that they're talking about is New York police boycott,
Quentin Tarantino's movies,
la coming out at the end of December,
by the way.
You know what I mean?
Like it's like such a promo and these things backfire when these people try to
do this stuff.
But it also makes people aware that what he's saying is you're responsible,
you know,
to call cops killers.
You think about how many cops and how many interactions with cops have all day
long.
I mean,
yeah,
it is terrible when like something like Sandra bland or all these different
scenarios take place where where people do wind up dying at the hands of cops.
It's absolutely horrific.
But to how many,
you look at the actual numbers of how many cops there are and how many
interactions these cops have with human beings and how many different
interactions happen during the day and how many times it leads to a real
problem.
Those problems for sure are horrific and the real issues.
But overall,
I mean to label all cops killers or all cops are murderers are all kinds of like
that.
It's,
it is in a way irresponsible and it's easy to do.
Did he say all cops?
I don't know what his words were.
I don't even think he did.
I think he said something to the effect of cops or cops have been murdering
innocent people,
you know,
something like that and you know,
for them to run with it.
I mean,
okay guys,
so wait,
wait,
what an imprint.
You're going to leave on this brand new,
you know,
hateful eight movie.
That's going to be the shit like the movie's supposed to be about.
God.
God,
what is she?
It's going to be so good.
Um,
it's about,
basically the gist is sorta like civil war.
It's sort of like Django meets inglorious bastards.
Like it's like civil war,
but like really bad ass.
Kurt Russell Civil War,
Huh?
Yeah.
Civil war mixed with like assassins and they kidnapped someone.
I was in the late 1800.
That's what I'm supposed to be two.
Yeah.
Dude.
Kurt Russell has this huge beard and this huge mustache.
So was he growing it for the movie or is it fake?
Oh,
it's real.
He fucking did it.
When,
how long you took him to gross on a long time.
They all do that.
Should they go?
They make them fucking work.
You Know Quentin,
you've seen Kel Bell.
Yeah.
He sent them all to Japan to train in the art of the Samurai Sword.
That entire assassination squad.
Deadly vipers.
David Carradine dedicate a Fox,
Michael Madsen,
Uma Thurman,
and um,
they're all Hannah.
They all went to fucking Japan and stayed in cool little Japanese fucking,
you know,
condos with like sliding jet.
Every,
everything was like super culture.
Wow.
For them to really get in the zone and they,
and you can see,
you can tell that they know what they're doing when they're doing their crazy
shit.
Like you can feel it in that movie.
I feel like at least.
Um,
but anyway,
yeah,
I mean like,
you know those cops are gonna see that movie.
They can say they're going to boycott at,
what are they,
I mean I would say they'd put on a fake mustache,
but they probably already have muscles dashes are going to shape their mustaches
to go sneak in.
Like,
Oh,
I'm not going to see this movie my ass.
You're going miss it.
Kurt Russell within all out beard in a civil war assassin saga.
Okay officer,
you're a locks.
You might as well,
you might as well just go kill innocent people.
You're going to,
so
I don't know what's it worth missing that movie are killing innocent people,
but I'm just are huge Terentino's nerd fan.
So I think everybody should take a,
he's definitely made some fucking awesome movies.
Paul Fisher was such a game changer.
You were watching on the way up here.
I looked over and I saw that,
uh,
that image of the girl and the guy at the diner at the beginning of the movie,
but they're talking to each other right when they kissed before they robbed the
place.
I'm like,
wow.
That's like the beginning of the stitch at ties.
That whole crazy movie together.
Yeah.
It's unbelievable.
Different timeframes of all that.
Okay.
You mean like when they come back to that at the end and they're robbing the
place and Travolta in Samuel hollers sitting there at [inaudible].
By the time that that happens at the end,
we know Travolta gets killed by Bruce Willis three,
well,
you know,
10 15 1520 minutes before that that Samuel l ends up retiring from the game
because of the holes in the wall where it's like all just like crazy.
I haven't seen that moving along.
Income,
I need to go watch it again.
Fun fact is I was watching it without the sound on.
I was listening to music and just had my headphones off because I know every
single inch of that movie so well that I don't even need to have the sound like
it's fun to have the sound,
but it's also fun to like see their lips moving and knowing exactly what's going
on.
Yeah.
I was doing the same thing with the Lord of the rings.
Did you end up watching that new mission?
Impossible.
No.
Oh God.
It was really good.
I was really surprised.
I'm not a mission impossible guy at all.
But this new one's great until some movies are so stupid.
I know.
But this song was like so good.
It was like funny.
There was really you times where I laughed out loud like I was like this is
fucking impressive.
Like I think all those are crap,
all of them.
But this one is like really well written.
Those movies.
It's,
it's hard to get me to sign up for like a bond movie or like a mission
impossible movie.
Cause like,
you know the Tom Cruise is going to be okay.
You know,
Daniel,
Craig's going to make it to the end of the movie.
Whatever bad guys he's facing is gonna wind up killing woe is almost going to
die.
But it knows in like,
right.
Like you know,
no matter what.
But
yeah,
there's always one of those scenes where they're dead and then like all of a
sudden somebody has the paddles and they jolt them back to life.
Yeah.
And what did I see recently that was like that?
Then I had a really hard time getting into,
cause I knew that,
oh the Martian,
I knew he was going to live like Lou,
my goal,
these rooms going right,
but there's not,
yeah,
it was no drama.
Like when they were talking about coming back to get them,
I'm like,
they're going to get them,
they're going to get him.
He's going to live like,
oh my God,
he's floating in space.
He's got to figure out how to get to them so they can grab them and bring them
on board.
They're going to figure it out.
Like there was no drama.
It was.
So it's,
it's so problematic when you have like a star and one individual star that is
responsible for driving the whole movie.
And the whole movie was based on Matt Damon getting off Mars.
He got trapped on Mars and they had to go back and get them.
So because of the fact that it was based on that,
like you knew he was gonna make it,
you knew there was no real suspense and one of the end of the movie was kind of
anticlimactic because you knew it.
Whereas
even a movie like alien,
like the original alien with Sigourney weaver,
you kind of knew that Sigourney weaver nurse was going to make it.
But the way they did it was so clever and they fucking killed off everybody but
her that it was okay.
It was okay cause it was so chaotic.
I've been on a movie rampage lately and I did purposefully didn't go see the
Martian.
Really?
Yeah.
I'm like allergic to Matt Damon.
Why are you allergic to bad date?
Oh,
there's just something about him.
I just think he's like the most overworked.
Overrated,
like just bland,
boring.
I think rounders would have been better without them.
I think Malcovich buried and in that movie he couldn't anything Malcovich
was doing with his Oreos and all that stuff.
I think Ben Affleck's the same thing and I think they're like this duo of dog
shit that just do
that.
Just like somehow they got this like goodwill hunting momentum and like
everybody's just like,
yeah,
that cool cause I found goodwill hunting.
It's like,
no,
I'm not buying it.
Ben Affleck's a tool he's not cool at all.
Matt Damon is like,
you know,
if you want to know about
how much of a tool Ben Affleck really is,
you have to watch them on real time with Gomar.
Watch you on real time with Bill Maher.
Were you accused of Sam Harris?
You know,
I don't know if you know Sam Harris is a brilliant intellectual who's written
many,
many books.
I'm diligent,
he's just fucking super genius.
And he accused him of being racist for his stance on Islam,
like radical Islam and fundamentalist Islam being like a really dangerous
proposition,
a dangerous ideology.
And he did it in such a stupid,
clunky,
like ignorant way and look so dumb and so,
so much forced outrage while he was doing it like you watch and do it,
you go,
oh my God,
fuck this guy.
See where are you doing?
He was totally going to like social justice Brownie points,
right?
Like trying to stand up for the oppressed and the way he did it was so awkward
and loud and shouty it was,
it was so dumb.
It was so dumb.
They did like you instantly,
instantly reveals how weak is actual argument was there was trying to back it up
by calling him a racist who was trying to like put him on the back of his heels
like,
but you can't do that to Harris because he's a master debater.
Like he debates with people all the time.
Are they just people all the time.
So when you do that he like never loses his cool,
which made Ben Affleck look even dumber.
And then Bill Maher is taking a Sam Harris society as well and they're both
going like,
I think you're missing what he's saying.
And he's like,
it's racist.
Oh my God.
Tracy just saying is so racist,
but it's so dumb and clunky and it just you,
you realize like the poor quality of his thinking and how high he holds his own
opinions.
Like what?
You know,
it's,
you have to see it.
It's so Tulise.
I'll never,
I mean,
I can't say I'll never respect his opinion again.
I value it so much less.
Well after watching that argument should boycott his movies.
He was good in gone girl though.
See gone girl.
He was good in gone girl.
But you know what?
I think that was just an extremely well written,
well directed movie that easily could have slept a,
you could've slept a Kevin Spacey in there and it's like,
no,
20% better.
Well,
yeah.
I mean,
I'm good son.
Yeah,
like gay and fat too.
You have to have someone younger and handsome.
But yeah,
you could have,
yeah,
I mean like aunt lil and haul it would act like crushed it.
Totally.
Much better.
There's something about Ben Affleck,
he's milk Korea.
Watch them and it makes sense.
You just know it's Ben Affleck.
Yeah.
It's like he doesn't,
he doesn't really break out of the,
it's never like a different,
you're never like,
oh,
I didn't even notice that was Ben Affleck.
You know what I mean?
Like how you have that,
that that's that way with so many great actors and like you're like,
oh,
I didn't even notice I was him.
Like,
he's so good in it.
Yeah.
I felt like that in that.
Um,
what was that movie that he did?
The town goes another movies like,
God,
anybody get it done that the town movie where he plays the bank robber guy.
Remember that movie?
No.
How many?
His buddies are all bank robbers from Charlestown.
Charlestown was like a real area of Boston that was filled with the Jed
criminals and they were like a legit high amount of bank robbers came out as one
area.
But he's done a bunch of those Boston movies too.
Yeah.
That's where it goodwill hunting was.
I love it.
South Park does with Matt Damon.
Yeah,
but he's not stupid.
So it's so funny when they do those like a,
when they did team America,
world police and he's like,
man came and made them so stupid,
but he's not stupid.
Oh,
I love it.
I think those guys are crap.
Just crappy crap.
Crap.
Yeah.
And they're an interesting duo.
I don't know.
It's hard to be an actor and not be a Douche bag and full of shit just to make
it through the ranks to get to a position where your actual movie star and all
the Dicks you've sucked along the way,
figuratively.
Not literally necessarily
like Christian Bale,
you know,
like he yelled at those people and stuff and,
but you know what?
Sorry is fucking good.
His fucking gun.
Well,
not only that,
the guys distracting him in the background lies in this really important
emotional scene and you want to shame him by recording that as if he's an
asshole.
But guess what?
The guy was distracting him.
A fucking with the lights.
That guy's an idiot.
Yeah,
you can have idiots like that on the set.
And they do ruin things.
Yeah,
they do.
They do.
And if he's a perfectionist,
like obviously he is.
Yeah.
He couldn't possibly be as good as he is without being a perfectionist.
When you have someone who's like irritating you like that,
that's on the set.
Yeah.
I could see him snapping.
It makes sense.
Yeah.
And it's like,
you know,
people are like,
Oh,
Christian Bale's a Dick.
It's like to that guy,
we don't even know who that guy was.
Right.
Maybe we met that guy.
I'd be like,
Oh,
you're a fucking moron.
Yeah.
Or else maybe we'd be hearing more of these clips of Christian Bale yelling at
innocent people instead.
There was just that one.
Yeah.
And it's like,
you know,
my patients grows a lot longer for people who I respect.
You know,
I have a whole bit about it.
You know about bill Cosby and woody Allen about the site.
You can get away with stuff if you're talented,
you make multiple hits and you're good.
You can get away with shit.
Well,
there's obviously a point of no return for her.
[inaudible] Cosby.
He can't get away with it anymore.
He stopped performing.
Remember in the beginning he was performing,
he had all these dates that he was doing while accusations are coming out and
people were still like yelling out,
we love you bill,
we love your bill.
But now even those people like damn bills and racist,
totally racist.
He is a rapist rather.
Yeah.
I think he's going to paternal out.
You know what I mean?
Like my show cancer now.
Yeah,
something like that.
Joe Paternal,
like the week that he retired,
it was so crazy.
Like I just watched it 30 for 30 ESPN documentary on it.
You ever watch those?
Yeah.
And it said they were talking about how literally the day that he announced his
retirement,
he went home and took a bloody poop.
Next day goes to the doctors like my poops bloody and I like,
yeah,
your body's filled with cancer right now.
It's like,
oh,
okay.
Like seven days later he was dead.
Something like that.
Wow.
It was like so fast.
Well,
he probably had the stress of knowing that he was harboring a child molester for
years.
It does probably eating away at him.
Besides the fact that he was an old guy as it is,
but you think about what kind of stress must be involved in having a guy like
that that you know is fucking kids and you don't know what to do about it.
You don't know what to do because he's got this whole charitable organization
where you're taking care of children and you know,
you know,
and everybody else knows he's fucking those kids.
And then when it comes out,
oh,
the world knows that you knew he was fucking those kids and you didn't do
anything about it and you should have and you are a coward and it just starts
rotting you out from the inside.
Oh yeah.
Oh my God.
It must be fucking devastate.
I mean it's like,
it's,
it's like almost like just being as bad as the pedophile,
except you don't even get to like blow those loads.
You know what I mean?
I would love to,
that's so rude to bill Cosby.
Bill Cosby does.
If it turns out that bill Cosby has cancer and he's dying and he wants to come
clean and he wants to talk about at all,
I would love to have him on a podcast in imagine having bill Cosby on a podcast
before he's dying.
He's asking him like what?
How did this all start?
Like what was this?
What was it all about?
Like when did you first drug somebody,
did you get like,
cause it is something that excited you.
Was it a convenience thing?
Like what was it that made you think that it's okay cause he has daughters,
right?
I believe he has gone,
Oh God man.
I can imagine.
I don't even,
I don't know how anybody could get into something like that.
Like it's so interesting.
It's such a weird like fetish because he clearly could have just had sex with
whoever he wanted.
Well we clearly could have just had prostitutes.
He's worth so much money.
Yeah,
you could have always done that.
Or he could have always like found someone who wanted to have sex with them.
But I think he liked drugging them.
It's the only thing that makes sense.
I think there's something it makes you wonder.
I don't know.
I've never heard
of it before,
but it's like,
you know what is that what?
What is that?
I spent a fetish then why couldn't you just pay a prostitute almost to do that?
Yeah,
but then it wouldn't really be happening.
See,
I think part of it had to be that he wanted a trip.
Those girls,
he wanted to give them a come over here and have a Cappuccino and it gives them
a Cappuccino and they're like,
oh you feel asleep are you?
And it just pulls his cock out.
You don't even see this dude.
Mm.
And then they,
you know,
throws him on the bed and pulled her panties off and Fox and other alcohol.
Like he must have been into that.
He must've been into the game of drugging them.
He must've been into like slipping them a Mickey and Washington blackout.
Yeah.
But then he's like stuck with them for hours while they try to sober up to,
how bizarre is that?
Like he had to be with them while they were out cold.
When he dropped them and he had to be willing to deal with it.
There's other ways he could have gone about it too.
Like you know,
like he could've just like,
you know,
I'm interested to know if he ever just had him come over and sat down and
watched like a Ben Affleck movie with them just to make them fall asleep instead
of drugging.
I'm,
you know,
just like,
oh,
you were allergic to the Matt Damon.
I don't think that,
I think that a guy like that,
a guy like Cosby is probably a sociopath in some sort of a strange way of a very
unique way.
EGOMANIAC a sociopath and feels like he's better than people and it feels like
it's okay.
It's okay if he drugs them.
I remember somebody,
I don't know if we can talk about this,
but what that person told us in that green room that one time about him.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
We could probably mention that.
I talked about that.
We've talked about it.
I've talked about it before.
Well,
okay.
She said that he,
he was at a casino and he made the security guard,
tuck him in,
come to his hotel room and talk to him in,
and this was all before the allegations came out,
but not much before,
like a few months before,
six months at the most.
And um,
we,
we were,
were there like right when all this was breaking.
It was over a year ago.
See that should've been a sign right there.
Anybody who needs to get tucked in,
she'd get like investigated by the FBI.
Right?
Well it's like why did you want to get talked in?
What's going on with that?
He and he also wanted people to watch him eat.
Do you remember that too?
He would have them sit down.
The whole staff,
like all the people that work there,
they would sit in his dressing room and watch him eat curry.
He would eat his food and they would sit around and he,
they didn't interact with them.
They would just sit around and watch him eat.
Wow.
Like what,
that's freaky stuff.
But what a weird request.
Yeah.
But I think he probably had a bunch of those weird things that he had his mind
that like,
like we're at this club last night and someone,
we don't have to mention their name,
but uh,
some comedian that we know.
Yeah.
And they were all saying what a piece of shit the guy was.
They would never have come back here again.
But that when they got to the airport,
he's like,
you know,
telling him to carry his luggage.
And then when people were there,
he's like,
don't,
don't let anybody touch me.
People come over and take my picture.
Don't let anybody touch me.
And then it's just like the weirdness of how he interacted with these people
that work there.
They're like,
look,
you'll never be back here again.
Right.
Like we just let you know right now.
You'll never,
you're never coming back here again.
Yeah.
Or they say we'd like the worst guy they had ever had come to their club.
But this guy who we're talking about hat all these weird ticks,
all these weird things that he would do,
like make people carry his stuff,
like things that he would do to clearly establish that he was better than that.
Right.
Make them sell his murder.
Yeah.
Things like that.
And that neurosis that these people have,
it's so ridiculous because most of the most talented people that I've met drive
their own car,
carry their own bag,
all of it,
and would be insulted if somebody tried that kind of stuff.
You know what I mean?
Like come on,
give me my bag.
Know,
you know like it's like the opposite because that,
that's simply not how success works.
There's no,
you don't get extra time to think because somebody else's carrying your bag,
then you have more,
you're more pride in the person that you're hanging out with because they're
carrying their bag and you're carrying your bag.
You know?
It just seems like the neurosis of it all is like such an old Hollywood myth.
Well,
it's one thing is,
is like maybe you had two big bags and like a driver came.
Let me help you with that.
They grab one of your roller bags and ask you some quite in pull it around.
Yeah.
But his thing was like making everyone do the work or he didn't want to carry
anything.
Right?
He wanted them to pick up his bags at the airport.
But I think when people demand preferential or special treatment like that,
they start to think of themselves as being superior to everyone else.
Everyone else,
you know,
throw your rose petals on the ground so that I may walk upon them.
You know,
this,
this idea that Cosby was better than all those people that he was drugging.
He was better than all those people that were watching him eat curry,
that he was better than that guy who he wanted to tuck him in.
Tuck me in.
I'm the king,
right?
I will lie in my bed and then when I lie on my bed,
then I want you to put the blanket over me and then I want you to Tuck it on
each side.
And I will rest and then you will leave.
Shut the night out.
The king is sleeping.
Yeah.
There's something creepy about that.
That's also the same kind of thing in some sort.
A way that I would allow him to have done all that horrific shit that he did.
Drugging those people [inaudible] no one's really gonna understand it unless he
talks about it.
Yeah.
Unless he comes clean and talks about it.
We're never going to understand his unique psychosis.
Love to know that.
Well,
it'd be the,
what would it be?
The first question,
like when did,
when did you do it?
Yeah.
When did you first do it?
Who was the,
did you see someone drug someone?
Was that a common thing?
I think people like slipping someone.
I'm Mickey.
They didn't think of it as that big of a deal back then.
Right.
I think it was a more,
I don't think they thought of it as rape.
I think they thought they were being sneaky,
but I think it was like,
like,
you know,
getting a girl,
getting her a couple of drinks,
have a couple of drinks,
relax.
Okay.
And voluntarily girl has a couple of drinks and you know,
once they have a couple of drinks,
they're going to loosen up.
They're going to be a little more playful,
little more uninhibited.
Whoa.
Next thing.
You know,
old sheds and millionaire.
Yup.
I wonder,
I wonder what,
what it was that started him down that path of drugging and raping women.
This lady was on TV and she was talking about it.
She's like,
he might be the most prolific serial rapist in history.
[inaudible] you stop and think about it.
Like that's fucking insane.
Bill Cosby might be the most prolific rapist in history.
He really could be already five lemon at least.
At least have accused him.
And those are the ones that have accused him.
The ones on the road like,
and he's been touring for ever everywhere.
He's just been going everywhere.
Chicks from Tennessee and the Oklahoma,
they're not gonna admit that stuff.
They don't even,
they don't even know what's going on
watching the news.
They don't even know other women are coming out with it.
You know?
And people with families.
Think of how many of those ladies must have families now and they're not coming
forward.
Well,
also they bought probably don't think what is the point,
right?
Adding their own story to a of 50 person story.
You're already dealing with a guy who was accused of multiple horrific crimes.
Like if you accuse him of one more is going to change anything.
Right.
There's one girl though that it's within the statute of limitations.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
There's one girl they're pursuing that is inside the statute of limitations and
if that comes through,
if they want to like he might actually wind up going to jail or at least
standing trial or,
I mean,
I don't know.
I don't know how it works.
I guess she asked to press charges and maybe he could bribe briber.
Maybe he could settle,
you know like that term settling out of court.
That's just driving someone.
Totally.
That's what he did in 2005 yeah.
The reason why we know about what he did was because of the deposition that they
released.
Once all these other accusations started piling up,
then they release the results of the deposition.
So we got to know that,
oh,
he admitted that he gave girls Qualia Woods,
you know,
and then he had,
I mean you can't get quite loose anymore.
Like this guy has some quotes stockpiled.
Yeah,
because I mean they,
they sh it that if they search they probably,
I mean they have probable cause.
Like what is happening with that case.
That's what's crazy.
You don't hear about it for months and months and months even,
you know,
updates.
Even the case has been put to sleep.
That's how son of a bitch.
And on that note,
I was going to make a probable Cosby joke and Denton admitted ago just to let
you know,
like the ones that I don't say like those exists too.
I don't just say,
oh no,
no.
When in Rome show
one of those things that we could talk about a million times in a row,
we always just bang your head against the wall.
They're just like,
it's almost like you're repeating the same conversation over and over again.
Like,
how could we do,
what was it about the Michael Jackson thing is really similar.
Like you repeat the Michael Jackson thing.
Many may too,
but he's dead so it makes it kind of weirder because you'll never know.
You'll never know if it,
if he really did those things or if he just got weird with those kids.
I had heard a weird possibility about Michael Jackson and I've talked about
before,
but that he was a cost Strada.
What's that means he had his balls removed.
Do you ever heard Castrato singing?
We never heard of that.
Oh my God.
They would have this,
uh,
they would have young men,
when they were really young,
they would castrate them and they would castrate them with the specific purpose
of making their voice sound a certain way.
You never heard of that
if it ever happened.
I bet it happened to him.
There were a type of opera singer.
They would do it on purpose.
Wow.
Yeah.
How crazy is that?
That they would castrate young boys so that there's sound would,
they would keep a certain sound you want to hear some of it?
Hold on a second.
I'll go.
I'm going to grab my laptop.
Hang in there folks.
Some walking across the hotel room to grab my laptop.
That's Michael Jackson may not have had any balls.
You will you think about his voice,
like the sounds that he was able to make with his voice.
Yeah,
I believe it.
His Dad probably did it.
It's on the one at the money.
Right?
Could you imagine if that's what he did?
Like he had a sound when he was young and so they castrated him so that he keep
kept that same sound.
It's cast,
Strada cast Radha music.
Castrato Castrato wow.
Yeah.
Kind of Straw.
That's insane music.
Yeah.
Well it's just how insane is it that that is a,
an actual style of music listening to the testosterone.
The testosterone
clearly would affect the voice box.
Nuts.
Yeah.
Jeez,
I didn't know that existed.
What's going on this
[inaudible]
that's a guy.
Yeah.
Aw.
This is the 1994 bio pics.
That might not be the jet,
but that's about one of the most famous cast rato singers.
Like,
here's a need to know.
Facts.
20 need to knows facts about cussed.
Roddys.
Okay.
The Vatican importeds very first falsetto singers from Spain.
It was considered preferable to have castrated boys singing the high parts since
girls and women were banned in the Vatican choir.
The 17th century was a bad time to be a good travel.
During the 17th century,
boys in Italy began to be castrated in increasing numbers.
This took place between the ages of seven and 11 to preserve the purity of their
unbroken voices so they could sing in church choirs.
Castration operations were performed by actual butchers.
Oh operations to remove a boy's tech testicles in medical terms was called
orchidectomy was where reputedly performed by the butchers of nor Rica,
nausea,
nausea and Italian region famous for its pork products where castration of pigs
was common cause they castrate pigs.
Um,
when they oftentimes with castrate pigs,
like in the wild and they let them go and then they try to hunt those pigs
because they can't breed,
but they eat a lot.
And so they get really fat and they don't have as much muscle.
It's a density of muscle which comes from testosterone.
So they become fat and thick and like this,
a softer meat,
only a tiny fraction of the children mutilated in this way.
Even made it onto the stage by the early 17 hundreds as many as 4,000 Italian
boys a year underwent the operation,
which was illegal.
Of those who survived,
only a fraction went on to train as opera singers.
And of those only a handful became superstars.
Being Castrato could have unexpected physical consequences.
The most famous Castrati,
we're trained in Neapolitan conservatories where they practice breathing
techniques for hours everyday to expand their lung capacities.
As a result,
adult Castrati,
we're often notably barrel chested.
They were tall compared to normal men of their time,
but they also had a shortened life expectancy.
Like look at the images of them.
These images where they showed this barrel chested,
tall guy like odd like that.
Like it's like he's got a little head,
little hands would a long tall torso.
Wow.
Yeah.
This is incredible man.
Really.
So this article is a symphony music,
N I,
music.com,
and it's all 20 facts,
20 known facts about [inaudible].
And some of them actually got married as poor bastards.
You know,
it's,
it's horrific man.
And there was,
there was an actual BBC documentary,
but here's an actual cus strati uh,
the only recording of an actual Castrato,
uh,
is a guy,
his name is Alice,
Sandro,
more g and he died in 1922.
So this is an actual,
sure.
Castrati we're going to listen to here.
This is a real one.
The other one that we played earlier was,
it apparently was a,
a sort of a recreation.
This is a,
a real castrati
[inaudible]
that's such a haunting shit.
That's a scary
[inaudible].
It's a guy with no balls.
[inaudible]
no,
stop and listen to this and stop you think about Michael Jackson thinking about
how salmon
[inaudible]
just how fucked up or people that they would even think to do this to a seven
year old boy.
How fucked up where the parents that let this your seven year old boy and let
him get as nuts chopped off.
So we do need better noise in his face
for some reason.
That's like the scariest that I've seen in a long time.
It's crazy.
Lose your balls without a choice and have it done by a butcher.
I mean,
Mike,
God,
I mean I think of all the things that ruins from now on.
You smelled bacon,
things like that.
Like it reminds you of getting your balls chopped off.
No,
doesn't Bacon.
I mean,
may be wanting to go into a butcher shop to do it.
It's a traumatic experience I'm sure.
Did traumatic part is listening to this tortured soul?
Oh No.
Just fucking grown man.
Who,
oh my God.
It's just,
it's insane.
That's freaky.
It's very freaky.
It's just,
it's,
it's hard to believe that people looked at human life like that.
I feel like this church next door keeps playing the bells.
Every time we talk about crazy shit that the Catholic church is that,
I wonder what's
worse is that the church sound?
The Bells wars.
Yes.
That's like a tortured soul and he's just going to say,
if you can really
mean that he didn't,
it wasn't like his fault.
[inaudible]
I wonder if when they did the autopsy of this on balls,
what if he didn't find balls?
Would they tell us they did the Michael Johnson ops on autopsy.
You can tell us shit.
Yeah,
that's like medical information,
right?
Yeah.
They wouldn't tell us he manages,
he went to his grave like that and nobody,
everybody kept their mouth shut and meanwhile he was castrated when he was
younger to make his voice sound better.
I guarantee you Joe Jackson knew about this.
I guarantee you this is not,
I mean,
if I know about this and people know about this,
people in the music business that actually are singers and that are a part of,
you know,
the industry they get definitely know about cost.
Toronto's.
Hmm.
I wonder man,
that's just my own personal theory by the way.
Yeah,
I mean,
and Michael Jackson could definitely hit some notes.
Yeah.
I mean like what's a song?
Think of a song where Michael Jackson like really nailed high notes.
Well,
I mean,
when he was in the Jackson five because of human nature,
right?
Yeah.
Well with the,
but I guess he was still a kid when he was in the Jackson five.
Right.
The Lis.
Listen,
this is human nature.
This is a song from,
um,
this is a song from when he was,
uh,
how old do you think he was when he did that?
He was a grown man for sure.
Right.
So this is waiting for this ad to run now.
He was probably in his thirties when he came over.
That's right.
[inaudible]
hello?
Hello?
Fuck.
Oh fuck.
Is that?
Oh Dad,
I think he may have been missing some of these people.
Nature
tough.
The look at the man in the mirror.
Fall out.
Fucking up.
Can you can't stop.
I know.
That's the sound he ever see when he caught his head on fire and the [inaudible]
screen.
Let's see what [inaudible].
Oh,
I can't listen anymore.
Yeah.
This is obviously just my theory.
Well,
I might've heard it somewhere to a matter of certain hurt other people.
I don't,
I've,
I've been thinking about this for so long.
I don't know.
But when you listened to the cost Toronto and then you hear that boy,
I mean,
he clearly wasn't hooking up with anybody.
I'm sorry.
But the Presley girl like that was clearly a media blitz,
like King of pop marries the king of it.
Even merrier.
Yeah,
we buried I think so.
Lisa Marie.
I didn't marry her,
I think so he kissed her.
But did he marry her?
I thought he married her.
They had school that they had like a fake kit or something together.
No,
they didn't have a fake kid,
but he definitely had fake kids with somebody else where it turns out there
wasn't even his sperm.
Right.
Well,
it would've been his sperm because his balls are in Joe Jackson's freezer right
now.
Okay.
Lisa Marie Presley.
Um,
let's see.
Hmm.
Did they marriage the personal relationships?
Michael Jackson tinted it that the,
let's see,
the intent,
the intent entertainer was said.
His first real date was with a child actress Tatum O'Neal when he was a teenager
in the 1970s he called her my first love after Diana Ross.
The pair eventually cooled off in quotes and Jackson entered into a romance with
model Brooke Shields in 1981 okay.
What,
although the relationship became largely platonic shields said there were times
we asked her to marry him as he grew older,
the two saw each other less.
Whoa.
Lisa Marie Presley by her father,
Elvis in 1974 blah,
blah,
blah.
Uh,
well.
Shortly after becoming involved with her in 1993,
Jackson was subjected to his first set of child sexual abuse accusations.
I didn't know that.
Followed by similar allegations in 2003,
Presley supported Jackson as became dependent on pain medication and eventually
helped convince him to enter drug rehabilitation and a telephone call.
You proposed marriage to Presley.
She agreed and the to wed.
Oh,
may 26,
1994 at a private ceremony in the Dominican Republic.
Why are we had to marry her?
Because he was on the child.
It'd be his thing.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
He doesn't have balls and isn't,
didn't she like eventually go on Lisa Marie to marry like,
uh,
somebody quicker.
It wasn't a,
the the actor with the,
his name,
the fuck's his name?
Billy Bob Thornton.
No,
no,
no.
Nicolas Cage.
Didn't she married Nicholas Cage?
I don't know.
I'm pretty sure she did.
Let's go to electrical.
Lisa Marie Presley.
Wikipedia has amazing relationships.
Let's go to relationships here.
Two,
two,
two relationships,
marriages
and relationships.
Bam.
She married one guy,
1988 by the Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
I'm Michael Jackson.
[inaudible] the
Michael Jackson spent four years falling or divorced together on and off to
attempt to reconcile bubble [inaudible].
Nicolas Cage.
Presley's third marriage was to Nicolas cage.
They're married August 10th,
2002 and Oceanside ceremony on the Big island of Hawaii.
Yeah,
whatever.
What the fuck she had.
She hooked up with some weird as well.
Imagine being an Elvis,
his daughter.
What a weird life that must've been.
He'd been married to the most famous guy the world had ever known at the time,
the most famous entertainer that had ever existed by falling.
It was never a guy like Elvis before Elvis because when Elvis came along,
he was like,
at the moment when movies and radio and television,
all that collided and someone could see a guy like that on TV,
on the outs,
Elvin show,
you know,
swinging his hips and you know,
Jailhouse Rock and women this.
Yeah.
Imagine as your fucking Dad,
imagine trying to be normal.
That guy didn't have a chance at being normal.
There was not like,
like today if you're Drake or if you're Jay Z or if you're fucking,
you know,
John Mayer,
there's a lot of those dudes out there.
There's a lot of them that girls would go crazy and scream for.
They can hang out together and go to parties and go,
man,
life's crazy.
Right?
Yeah,
Bro.
Life's crazy for us.
But Elvis had Elvis,
that was,
well,
is there Fabian?
Fabian had like one song,
I don't even know it'd be,
was like a heartthrob for a very short amount of time in the fifties it was like
a couple other guys,
but Elvis was uniquely famous,
like in a way they're like,
until Michael Jackson came along,
there's probably nobody liked him or close to it or very few people.
I can imagine that poorly.
Some marines,
his daughter,
I can't really take Elvis seriously as an actor.
Have you ever seen any of his movies?
Cause they talk shit.
You don't take them seriously as an actor though.
It's not an actor and a singer.
That's how I feel about Matt Damon and Ben
[inaudible] fuckers can't even say,
maybe they should be singing.
Maybe Mr Calling.
Yeah,
that's cut off their nuts and
I wouldn't mind seeing if it works.
And on that note,
we've got a,
we're going to hit the gym and work out what times here it is.
Three 50 here in wonderful Melbourne,
Australia,
which by the way,
Melbourne is the fucking shit.
How great is this town?
Amazing.
God Damn.
It's fun.
Last time.
It was incredible.
Yeah.
All right.
That was two hours.
So a,
that's it is the end of our podcast from Melbourne.
You can catch Tony Hinchcliffe on Twitter.
It's Tony at Tony Hinchcliffe,
um,
killed Tony.
Is this a
one shot?
Can you announce anything?
No,
no.
But know coming soon to a major internet distribution network that you're all
know of.
Yes.
We can say the name of it.
And when I get to announce that,
I'm going to hopefully come back on again and talk with Joe again about more
fun.
Yeah.
Yes,
indeed.
Yes.
All right.
We got two shows tonight.
Two sold out shows at some giant theater was at the Palais Palais theater,
I think it's Pele alive.
How?
Yeah.
Palais theater tonight in Melbourne.
And we're fucking psyched.
And uh,
all right.
That's it folks.
That's the end.
Anything more to say?
Time?
Uh,
I'd like to just say,
even though this isn't out yet,
good luck to a Johana NGH second tomorrow.
Uh,
I'm a huge fan and I love your striking and,
uh,
you know,
if we accidentally end up on a date some time,
uh,
woopsy but I think you really like my sense of humor and I am a little bit
bigger than you.
So like,
I know pictures of me,
I look really small,
but I'm like 140 pounds,
so thank you.
And,
uh,
good luck.
No.